So we know now how to create a character
and have them respond to input
and have them animate as they do so.
But what is the glue
that binds all of these classes together?
Let's take a look at how we set up a world in Unreal.
There are two main classes
that handle what game is being played.
Firstly, we have the game mode
and this handles the rules for the current game.
That could be how many players are allowed to connect,
where do these players spawn
and how many points will earn a team a win.
The game mode is the intended home
for this kind of logic.
And in a networked game, the game mode is server only
because we need it to be authoritative.
The game state on the other hand
is a replicated actor
that contains all of the pertinent information
about the set game mode.
Let's take capture the flag as an example.
The game mode would handle actually capturing the flag
and the allocation of the points.
Those points are then stored in the game state
where any client can easily see them.
There's also a third critical class that we can implement
and that is the game instance.
While the game mode and game state
are destroyed and recreated between levels,
think of the score beam reset when we move to a new map,
the game instance is created
as soon as the game EXE is executed
and persists across all maps.
We use the game instance to store data
that we want to transfer between levels.
Building on our capture the flag example,
so we pick the red team in the main menu.
When we load into the actual gameplay map,
we'd want the game mode to assign you
to the team of your choosing.
As the game instance persists,
we can safely bring that data along from the main menu
over into the main level.
The game mode gives us exceptionally useful
virtual functions to implement,
allowing us to shape any kind of game mode
that we would choose.
The game mode is the default class
that comes with the engine as a 4.14
and is a more streamlined version of game mode base
with a lot of the convenience functions
we'd expect of most standard multiplayer modes.
As an example, we have the init game function
and this is called exceptionally early in the game flow.
This is our initial kickoff
and it's called even before
the pre-initialize components function.
It's used by the game mode base
to initialize parameters and spawn any helper classes.
Additionally, we have pre-login
and this is called as new players request to join the game
and it's ultimately in charge of accepting
or rejecting that connection.
It's called before the proper full fledged login function
with a potentially non-trivial time in between the two,
especially if the joining player
has a lot of content to download before joining.
We also have post login
and this is called after a successful login
and it's the first place it's safe to call
any replicated or networked functionality
on the joined client.
We've got a nice convenience function here
called on post login that can be hooked up in blueprint
for a designer to expand.
So say we want to add some kind of UI sting
to the screen saying someone has joined the game.
Next, we've got the handle starting new player function
and this is called after post login.
By default, it spawns the pawn in
but we could extend it to do anything we want to,
say, changing the mesh of a particular player
or assigning them to a team.
Next, we've got spawn default pawn at transform
and this is a function
that actually does the spawning of that pawn.
And finally, we've got logout
and this is called when a player leaves the game
or is destroyed.
On logout is called in blueprint.
So say we want a player has left the game UI prompt
to show on the screen.
Any number of classes extending off of game mode
can be created all with different rules.
So your classic capture the flag, death match
and search and destroy would all be game modes
with their own sets of rules
and methods for spawning players in.
When talking about game mode as opposed to game mode base,
we have access to match states.
For example, we have the match state entering map
followed by in progress and waiting to start.
Waiting to start being your classic
waiting for more players to join state.
From there, we've got waiting post match.
Say we want to view the player scores
or vote on the next level to travel to
before proceeding into the leaving map state.
The Unreal Engine goes through a game flow
that determines when the necessary classes are initialized.
Similar to the life cycle of an actor,
how all this flows will depend differing
on whether or not you're starting in the editor
or launching a standalone game.
So the first thing we need to notice
is that when we start from the editor,
we initialize the editor engine
and then we start the engine proper.
It's only once we've hit play in editor button
that we actually create the game instance.
Whereas in a standalone game,
we initialize our game engine
and then create the game instance.
From there, we can see that we differ slightly
in the steps taken after the creation of the game instance.
However, both paths eventually lead
to calling begin play on the world.
All of this information is worth bearing in mind
when you actually come to decide
where to place any of your game logic.
As we can see with the spinning up of the game instance,
it happens exceptionally early on in the process,
whereas the game mode only exists
when the gold is ready to start playing.
The game mode can be set in a few ways.
The first is to set it on a project level
through the game map settings section
in the default engine.ini config file
with your usual ini key pair syntax.
We can also set it on a per level basis
through the world settings tab in the editor.
This is very useful when you want to consider
non-gameplay maps such as the main menu.
We may just want a level with no real gameplay rules,
just a map to load into to act as an entry point
for any player input.
As mentioned previously, the game state is responsible
for keeping track of game mode data.
More specifically, it keeps track
of the data that is intended to be visible
to all connected clients.
That might be the score, the time until the end of the game,
the time since the start of the game,
or even the list of other players in the match.
It's the game state that replicates down to clients,
giving them access to the current state of the game,
not the game mode.
The game state shouldn't, however,
keep track of specific player data.
There's a class specifically for this
called the player state,
which we're gonna touch on in just a moment.
The game state is trivially expandable.
It's basically just a publicly accessible
replicated class that contains data.
So most use cases are to simply add additional variables
depending on the game mode that you're authoring.
Much like the game state,
there's also a player state class
and it's intended for much of the same uses.
This is for storing player data,
say your own score during a death match.
Consider the following.
We have a death flow that results
in the porn being destroyed,
which is a fairly typical flow.
We have our player die and let them get respawned
through the restart player function in the game mode.
But where do we keep their score?
We could keep it in the player controller,
but that doesn't really make much sense
in terms of architecture.
And this is where the player state comes in.
We can add any number of variables to our player state
and have them survive our game's death flow.
The player state is also replicated
and fully supports client to server remote procedure calls
or RPCs because they're ultimately owned
by the player controller.
And this is gonna give us a direct line of communication
from the client to the server.
The player state is set through the game mode.
The game mode has a public member
called player state class.
And it's here that we actually set the class
that we intend to use as the player state.